this is a JVC HD 40 tapeless camcorders
this is the newest one Oh uses a 120
gigabyte hard drive oh yes solid-state
yes oh I am right you know that's huge
right how many hours of footage could I
get about 50 hours straight that you
could at the very high definition about
15 hours 15 15 okay way to and pick two
which is true high-definition true super
true high-definition 1080p quality that
you can get up at this camcorder so
quite I like 1920 by 1080 1920 by 1080
that's true High Definition one of the
things about this that you that other
cameras do have is a touchscreen you
know that's kind of a problem for this
one if you are into it and that's no
touch screens I'm not such no touch
screen for them that's okay because you
don't get a bunch of finger prints
everywhere right well yes and no the
problem is that the user interface is
not that good if we go in here really
quick you can check it out it's just a
bunch of text that looks terrible so
it's not it's not yeah it's definitely
not really easy like a lot of the new
camcorders are you know high-colored
huge candy colored icons you can just go
in there and you know I want you know
like right now we'll be in a room we
have the lighting specifics we're
outside we go in here now I have to go
and check like 17 different settings in
a text so I'm a little bit lost in here
hey you know what I really like about
this thing uh what times this existence
this look how small this thing is this
is literally about the size of a can of
energy drink oh where did that come from
launched it oh that's great okay Hosea
are you recommending this camera to me
like I've never had a tapeless a few
camera before should I buy this that's a
really really tough question I would say
no at this point because it's too
expensive how much is it $1300 oh my god
that's the main thing it's a quality
camcorder but there are other
much better cameras at this point for a
lower price for example we have the
latest Panasonic we have a Hitachi which
is a blue or a camcorder one of them is
tapeless which is also a really really
good camcorder and that's the next level
up next level up I've been taking some
videos with this it's pretty good
quality once it's in your hard drive in
your PC you can make some cool stuff
with it you know you know in the
meantime I think I'm just gonna stick
with my Rockstar do it yeah much more
delicious than drinking that can I can't
really do that
you